[Music]
atlanta hotlanta the atl all names for
one of the south's most exciting cities
and my home for a week let's check out
all that the city of the forest has to
offer i started my day with a visit to
one of the most popular local
destinations the world of coca-cola
now sold in over 200 countries coca-cola
the sweet elixir was invented right here
in atlanta in 1886
the world of coke is a beautiful
facility and it's also the location of
the vault that holds the formula for
making coke
but it's a secret
my favorite was the product tasting
center where you can sample sodas from
all over the globe drink up because it's
all free
i gave this one from india a thumbs up
i also tried the enigmatic beverly from
italy which tasted like a grapefruit's
armpit
but there's nothing like the original
just be careful you don't get too
carried away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the exciting things for me about
atlanta is one of my favorite television
shows is shot here the walking dead
and i got to meet jake garber here and
he's got a special treat in store jake
ready to be a zombie
or a walker as we call him on the show
yes i am
wow a chance to be one of atlanta's most
popular current citizens a real live
walker oops i mean a dead walker this
painstaking process takes almost two
hours so i was pretty antsy by the time
jake was finished
wow
i looked incredible but i couldn't hang
around set all day as there was so much
more of atlanta to see so it was off to
the aquarium for me
the georgia aquarium is the largest
aquarium in north america opened in 2005
it's home to over 500 species of aquatic
life let's check it out shall we
what an amazing place so many strange
and fascinating creatures
i even got to feed the rare albino
alligator
ouch
hey there baby beluga
you never know who's gonna pop up at the
aquarium
don't forget to pose for a photo they
make great souvenirs
and for those of you looking for a more
highbrow cultural experience there's the
world-renowned high museum of art
[Music]
picasa was right the purpose of art is
to wash the dust of daily life off our
souls
my final stop cnn center home to the
news network of note cnn
i'd make a pretty good cable anchor man
this is cnn
but the true stars of atlanta are its
people they couldn't have been
friendlier and even though i might be a
yankee they treated me like i was one of
their own
atlanta truly is the capital of the
south a metropolitan city with plenty to
offer both the short-term and long-term
visitor
and i didn't even get a chance to tell
you about the food
nice job
you did a lot of good for atlanta i'm
thinking about getting my own pbs travel
show
you should do a pbs travel show just as
a zombie wouldn't you watch it